this is a question that I have for you
guys what to call these sweethearts yes
no
conversation Hearts we came from the
same family but I don't know where your
Twisted little brain call them
conversation called conversation hurts
they've always been called conversation
look freaking on the bag this is the
authentic sweet no it's not you're
ruining everything and in my lifetime
I've never once oh I love when a boy
gives you conversation heart no one's
ever gave me a valentine I'm sure no
they're called conversation but it's on
the bag that's the generic rip-off
version of the sweethearts they can't
call them sweethearts it's a lawsuit
we're proud to be your favorite candy
maker for over a hundred years okay how
many years have you been making candy
when were sweethearts candies invented
1847. oh I just wanna
see what we'll do uh I'm wrong put that
on your conversation hard eat it